the draft approaching and plenty of
people saying
plenty of things some of which may be
credible some of which
may not be ryan day ohio state coach
talking about
his quarterback justin fields who will
have pro day one
today here's day
whatever they teach in terms of a scheme
he's going to pick that up very very
quickly and he's very very competitive
so when you combine the talent the size
the arm strength
his competitiveness his toughness
intelligence
i mean it kind of checks all the boxes
and if you were
trying to design a quarterback uh you
know to me
you know justin fits that prototype
whether he's
you know ready made to be the number one
pick in the draft that's up to them
you know i mean every team has to make
their own decision but i know this
everything you invest in that kid you're
going to get back and
it's just a matter of the fit someone's
going to take a shot at him here
early in the draft and they're going to
have a franchise quarterback for a long
time
hey and justin fields was great against
clemson in the semifinal
game some of the throws he made and just
the toughness playing through
whatever that injury was right clearly
in distress
you know there was a time where he was
kind of hovering around
as number two right second quarterback
after trevor lawrence
and then zach wilson gets shoved into
that spot and now
fields is just kind of in this weird no
man's land
unless it is one hell of a ruse that
you're in on by the 49ers where it's not
really mac jones but it's justin fields
unless that's the case
i don't know where fields is gonna go i
don't know either you know you're right
he's kind of the uh forgotten man
right now out of the the five
quarterbacks in the first round
man you know there's like we talked
about a little in the first hour there's
a lot to like
i mean there's no doubt that justin
fields is a first round quarterback
and again the thing that he can bring to
your team right away
and allow him to be a starter even
though i think he's raw in a lot of
areas still
hey i mean it's it's he's a greek god
like you just heard
you know coach day talk about there he's
built like cam newton just a little
shorter
i'm i'm excited i don't even know if
he's running the 40 today at that ohio
state pro day or not but i'd be really
interested to see what he runs because
that is the first thing that jumps out
to you when you watch him you go whoa
the running is more dangerous than i
gave it credit for
watching on tv especially the size of
the human being but he looks like he's
the type of guy that could run a low 4-4
mike it's that type of running but but i
go back to your question
that's really that's where i find the
49ers trade
really intriguing in a lot of ways too
because
it could now start that run of
quarterbacks to where
it just becomes a little bit desperate
in the top half of the first round
you know yeah i'm sitting here right now
going trevor lawrence jaguars
zach wilson jets mack jones 49ers
if you listen to anybody in football
they think the atlanta falcons are hot
on trey lance
i mean everybody thinks every that when
i hear that many people
talking about one guy to a place and
then i even hear
guys you know who are privately telling
me they're hearing that behind the
scenes too
that's when i do listen to draft stuff
right
so now you have one two three four mike
and then you go
okay now who do we look at who next
who's next on the list and you go
eight carolina panthers could they be in
the justin fields conversation
i mean i don't think that's crazy so we
could be sitting here in a thing where
we look at five quarterbacks going top
10 top 12.
not that i think they're all top 10 or
top 12 material but i think it's very
possible
and if i'm the bengals at five with all
the needs that i have
yeah and it's four quarterbacks in the
first four picks and fields is still
there
that's when i'm calling the panthers the
broncos any other team that may be in
play for fields
saying start the bidding let's go sure
you got 10 minutes
yeah i agreed i think you you know you
would hope that
yeah if you're the bengals you could sit
there carolina maybe the denver broncos
who knows the new england patriots
sitting there at 15
would they try to make a move and go
this route of football
i mean hey justin fields behind cam
newton for a year or do
i could see that that makes sense uh
fields
like we talked about big great athlete
played in some big time games you know
unbelievable arm
strength unbelievable i mean can throw
it through a wall
but as you heard when we broke it down
too when it goes bad at sometimes he can
miss that wall
altogether you know so he could throw it
through it and when it's really good you
go whoa look at these throws this looks
great
but then all of a sudden he has games
and times during a game where you go
whoa okay mechanics are failing
balls all over the place you know bad
decisions ball all over the place and
that's to me where
i would love to see justin fields get in
that situation where he could sit for a
year
and kind of work on some things and go
from there because there is high end
talent i just don't think he's nfl ready
this second
we talked earlier about three alabama
first round quarterbacks to date
mac jones will be number four ohio state
don scott 1941
arch sleepster 1982 dwayne haskins
2019. yeah justin fields if he goes in
round one as he likely will he will be
number four
so the the thread through the popcorn in
this segment is a fill in the blank
question and now that we've
discussed justin fields let me ask you
this chris okay whoever drafts
fields is getting what
uh i'm gonna say uh a specimen with a
high
ceiling that's that's what i would say
you know there there's
there's i think a little bit of a low
floor with justin fields
but i think like the high end potential
is real
when you talk about it you know we
talked about the arm strength and the
ability to run and the size of the
player and all of those type of things
i mean they're they're real they are and
if you could put that together then
you're going to have something special
you know in a few years um but those are
those are
those are big ifs in my opinion to fix
some of the foot issues to fix some of
the arm issues and things like that
and let alone you know on film
you see some of the things you saw from
dwayne haskins and cardell jones that
were kind of like the things that were
concerning a little that way
too as far as ohio state quarterbacks
and just
throwing to wide open guys and being hey
first read and then
oh no i don't know what's going to
happen after that that's to me where
he's raw
and that's where it's you know you got
to feel comfortable that the guy's going
to be able to develop and go in the
right way to take him high in the draft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports